and you thought digital was forever
that's what they tell you turns out is
not true when it comes to the federal
government in the middle of a scandal
though the FBI now says it lost
thousands somehow of text messages
between Peter Strock and Lisa page
relevant to the conversation we're
having tonight President Trump has
reacted to those missing messages just
moments ago here's part of what he said
I do worry when I look at all of the
things that you people don't report
about with what's happening if you take
a look at you know the five months worth
of missing texts that's a lot of missing
texts and as I said yesterday that's
prime time so you just want to look at
that and say what's going on you do look
at certain texts where they talk about
insurance policies or insurance where
they say the kinds of things you're
saying you can't be concerned well it's
not even the first time the government
has mysteriously lost communications
central to an investigation you may
remember Lois Lerner / the IRS and how
24,000 of her emails were accidentally
deleted somehow and then of course
Hillary Clinton's 33,000 deleted emails
tom Fitton is the president of Judicial
Watch he lives in a world where emails
are mysteriously deleted he's doubled
this a lot he joins us tonight for
perspective time my impression was and
our cybersecurity guys are always saying
if you write it down digitally it never
goes away why is that not true for
federal documents in the middle of
investigations
well it's only true if it's convenient
to withhold the information from
investigators and the American people in
the case of Lois Lerner they told us
well we didn't keep some of her emails
that are no backup tapes it turns out
there were backup tapes and we ended up
getting a lot of those emails with
Hillary Clinton we asked for Clinton
emails they said well there's nothing to
give you it turns out she had them all
she tried to delete half of them and we
now are getting the emails that she
deleted her otherwise hid so this is
just a matter of law enforcement going
in and recovering this material if
indeed it needs to be recovered or
finding it where it's hidden and if I
were the Attorney General of the United
States I would be very concerned about
what the FBI did here and I would send
an independent law enforcement like the
u.s. marshals to secure and recover this
evidence I'm a little confused though
because these are not favors people are
asking of the government if you're a
member of Congress on a committee
investigating something or if you're a
citizen filing under the Freedom of
Information Act you have a legal right
to these documents if a government
bureaucrat lies to you and withholds
them what's the penalty to him for that
well there could be obstruction of
justice obstruction of Congress
destruction of government property
government records or charges ever
brought on those grounds they are if
you're not Hillary Clinton where were
they in the Hillary case or the Lois
Lerner case anyone go to job no lying
about that know what so what's your best
guess here I confess I'm not an expert
on digital questions but five months of
emails disappearing from an agency
that's famous for understanding how
digital matters work it's hard to
believe what do you think the truth is
well I think maybe there was a technical
glitch but there was a little interest
in resolving it and little interested in
resolving it still and it's only going
to be resolved with significant law
enforcement interest and I don't think
the FBI can be trusted to investigate
itself and this is why we need
independent law enforcement and Congress
ought to initiate its own inquiry as
well but this is pretty serious these
that these text messages are about the
activities of FBI agents who have been
implicated in massive abuses of power at
the FBI have ruined the Clinton
investigation in terms of its
credibility and in many ways this isn't
even about FBI text this is about the
Mueller investigation because Peter
struck who's at the center of this was
the key investigator in the Russia
collusion investigation
who knows what evidence he has gathered
as a result of his partisanship that has
now been tainted and I think there's
this race going on at this point where
Muller is trying to get Donald Trump
interview yeah before this memo comes
out and before more text messages come
out that further undermine his already
really low-quality investigation the
president could declassify it by the end
of this show she could click as heels
three times we could get the underlying
by as a warrants rather than if relying
on Congress to write a memo about it we
ought to Tom thank you you're welcome